mark on the movie a director has to know
a thousand different jobs whether it be
writing story lighting sound makeup
working with actors editing so on and so
forth when it comes down to it what do
you think is the most important job of a
director okay the most important job to
me is really simple you think about it
first of all the director of a film is a
storyteller thank everybody who he's
working with is there to help tell one
story so the directors primary job is to
be the shepherd of that story take care
of the story and tell the story as
clearly as honestly and as authentically
as possible I say story not the script
the script which we can talk about later
is a step towards getting the story told
in terms of your question what you're
asking about in terms of the story being
told at the center of the story the most
important part of the story are the
characters it's the characters who tell
the story not the cinematography not the
production design not all those other
elements all those other elements or
support system to the story so the
director needs to be focusing on the
story and then on the characters and the
strength of the performances the
authenticity of the performances the
clarity of characters the clarity of
relationships the clarity of the journey
of each character is really crucial in
order to tell the story well that's the
primary focus of the director if a
director can't do that or loses sight of
that the story is going to start to
wobble and we've seen that a lot stories
which wobble because simply because of
performance even though one of the other
elements may be brilliant like CGI and
special effects and all that all that
stuff is beautiful it's wonderful but
it's not the story it's the story
wobbling because the actors are wrong
for the part when you say shepherding
the story where would that get lost
where would the director in the course
of let's say a 14-hour day onset working
with
who's that can you give some examples of
what things could happen or how things
could have you brought up two things
what could happen in a 14-hour day and
then you've brought up a casting
question so there are two questions you
know
if the actor is right I'm going to go
back to the casting first first of a
casting which is really crucial and very
often we've all seen films where we feel
the casting
although understandable is not right
doesn't feel like that actor is bringing
me closer to the character and many
times that actor is a star whatever so
you can understand why so the casting is
really important that we the audience
the goal is that we the audience lose
sight of the actor and are only watching
the character and many times the actor
even the power of the actor or the the
career of the actor or a lot of other
things can get in the way of us
connecting with the character one more
thing in casting you can cast someone
who can't seem to get to the character
just nothing to do with star power
so casting is really important to find
someone who can actually access that
character now in a 14-hour days I'd say
the 14-hour day only shooting a couple
of scenes or one scene or whatever we're
doing in that day you ask how the
director can lose sight of the
shepherding of the story very easily
very easily and I can tell you as a
director and having directed a lot of
film and having worked on a lot of films
you can see it happen
it's what a friend of mine mark Riedel
who I worked with a lot called the big
machine the big machine is the
filmmaking process cameras lights crew
all of it's huge
you've been on a set you know what it's
like it's enormous and the director is
sort of the leader the guy that
everybody is looking to and what could
happen is the director gets distracted
by all the challenges everything he has
to do I'm not saying it doesn't have to
do that I have to do all that and can
lose sight of what is most important
you're shooting that close-up of that
actress at that moment what's the most
important the light
know the background know the special
effects know what's most important is
that performance I heard once on a set a
director after it shot a moment turn to
the script supervisor and say did she
say all the words the script supervisor
says yes he says okay good
moving on his his criteria was did she
say all the words not was that the
performance we need in other words can
the director keep their focus on the
performance because when it comes down
to the film and we see it on the screen
what do we see the performance the big
thing that mark Riedel told me about is
you can be on a set and watching oh that
was great
that was wonderful you can even be in
dailies and watch it later go great
wonderful you can see at home later and
go huh what happened to great and
wonderful the machine is taken away a
lot of directors get their energy from
the big machine from the fact that
there's a crew when there are lights and
energy everybody goes quiet everybody's
listening Wow there it get excited by
the fact that they are shooting the film
and that excitement will go away and
then you look at the shot and go what I
thought it was great when we did it what
happened what happened was there's an
energy around you which is now gone so a
director's job is can you shut down the
big machine can you focus your attention
onto just what that actress is doing
what she's getting to you can you see
only that now that's really hard and one
other aspect of this assuming that
you've been working with this actress a
lot and you've rehearsed and you've
discussed this intention so you know
what you're going for and you know what
she's going for can you watch her in
that moment not only shut down the big
machine but can you watch her in that
moment as if you've never seen her
before
and you're seeing what she's doing it
for the first
that's hard the hardest thing a director
has to do what are two or three things
that a director cannot afford to get
wrong because if they do the movie is
ruined
wow that's a big question two or three
things I can't get wrong cannot afford
okay I'll there's one thing I think
Aaron that I think is really important
that and I include myself in this that
we all fall into a trap that we all fall
into and what I call it is the trap of
assumption okay the cap of assumption is
let's say I have a script and I really
like it and I'm moved by it okay my
assumption will be that other people
will be moved by it somebody else will
could read it or see this film or
whatever and be moved in it I could be
wrong I'll even take a scene have a
scene between say a husband and a wife
and there's an argument going on and the
husband is really angry at the wife of
some reason and it's to me it's clear
he's angry at her because of her
attitude her impatience now I've gone to
something very small and my assumption
is that the rest of anybody out watching
it would get that it may not be true the
problem is this when we look at in the
script on ask in a script I'm just going
to take one scene I can read that same
hand and I can read it the sides say
it's just two pages I can read that
scene and I go I got it I can see what's
happening I can feel all the energy
between the two characters I can feel
the conflict I can feel the resolution I
can feel all the obstacles everything
that they're going to I get it now quite
honestly those two pages none of what I
felt is there I can tell you that right
now none of it none of the conflict and
even the characters is there all it is
is words typed on a page no different
than a novel no then it's just words on
a page what happens which we all have to
recognize
is when you look at a script you project
into that material what you believe is
happening you actually anybody who reads
the scripts can suddenly hear the
characters they can see the characters
where is that coming from it's not
coming from the page it's not there
there's no pictures of the characters
there there's no action there nothing
there's no emotion there there's no
performance there nothing so what we do
at every human being does is we project
into those pages what we believe is
happening in other words those pages are
triggering me those pages that I'm
reading trigger mark marks history marks
life experience marks expectation
everything it's coming from me so I
project into it now Karen you'll do the
same thing but why should I assume that
your projection is the same as mine
that's the danger of assumption I assume
that you'll get it the same way I do not
true maybe close I don't know so the
trap is the trap of assumption I assume
that you're going to respond that way I
could see a scene ago that's so moving
and you're going what I don't get it now
my reaction was it was moving here so
what was it my assumption is you should
get it so thinking that just because it
works for me it should work for
everybody else yet ironically the flip
side of that is also true as a director
have to make the movie for me I can't
make it for anybody else so I have to
allow a certain level of assumption to
going on I'm assuming because I made a
movie that I really like this moving to
me I have to assume that it's going to
be moving to enough people that the lots
of people are going to like it so we're
trapped
in the world of assumption but trapped
in that we have to do it but be aware
that it could be a problem okay so how
is someone aware of their own
assumptions so let's suppose you think
these two pages of very moving dialogue
between two
characters is just heart-wrenching
because you see the world that way or
that scene but how are you bouncing that
off someone else or I don't know if I'm
yeah yeah yeah I think so and I think I
have an answer for it let's stay with
this one scene because sometimes just
looking at one say cuz if a movie is you
don't make a whole movie as you know you
make these all these little scenes you
put together it becomes a movie
so let's and you have to be very focused
very myopic about that scene so let's
say we have a scene between a husband
and wife and getting back to you how do
I deal with my assumptions I'll tell you
one of the biggest assumptions eyes a
director can have any director will have
every director will have I read this a I
know how it should play I is the
director know how this scene should play
should now I'm the director so I get to
decide I get to decide how I want the
actress to play the mother and how I
want the actor to play the father now
this is what a lot of actors to do it I
could a lot of directors will do them so
that's what a lot of directors will do
and I can tell you right now because
working with a lot of directors I'll say
to a director who says this is how it
should go I said how do you know well
that's that's clearly the way it should
play I said how do you know I'll talk to
them about projection so there's that
assumption now we're going to mix with
that something else which makes it even
more difficult you have the two actors
now those two actors read the same
they're making assumptions
the actress Aoi I know how to play this
the actual says I I know how to play him
now we have three people who have
different points of view on how it
should play and I can tell you right now
the director nee and those two actors
right we're all wrong we are all wrong
we are right about our assumptions we
are right about our opinion but we are
wrong our opinion actually does not
matter all three of us the only opinion
that matters is the opinion of the
actors the character the husband life
they know and we're trying to tell them
how they should behave
the actors are trying to tell them how
to behave by controlling them I'm trying
to tell the actors how to control the
characters how to portray the characters
if I can get to the character get to the
truth of the character my assumption may
be blown right out of the water and the
actress may be too or may not I don't
know but my job as the director is to
serve the characters that's getting back
to what your question was before serve
the story not my version of the story
their version of the story I want to get
to the truth of who they are I want to
get to the truth of these characters
that the writer created that the writer
is also making assumptions about and the
writer may even tell me oh it should go
this way I said well I don't know if you
know either let's get to the character
and this gets down to the interrogation
process which is talking to the
character I want to know from the
character what they want what they think
what they feel and one thing that's very
important which may have been in the DVD
I gave you it probably is but one thing
that's very important this is a concept
as is so to me is so clear and so
obvious but nobody talks about it
well soon as I bring it up in Bologna
the characters in your movie the
characters in this scene these two
people this husband and wife whoever
they might be
are not in a movie
they're not there to people who are in
their life there in a moment in their
life which happens to be the scene
trying to achieve whatever they're
trying to achieve they're just two
people they're not in a movie they don't
they do not have a script and we are
trying to present them as authentically
as we can to a viewer well in order to
do that we need to honor them not my
point of view necessarily not the
actor's point of view necessarily but
then let's let's present them as
authentically as we can I have learned
so much about characters and story by
talking to the characters by in a way
and I mean it seriously dismissing a
little bit what the writer says what the
actors say and even what I think and I
go and I talk to the characters and I am
sometimes so educated and enlightened
about who these people are know they're
the ones I'm here to serve they're the
ones that the writer is here to serve
that the ad were all there in service of
characters so let's talk to them now the
interrogation process which we can talk
about later is a way to get to them and
get us the writer the director and the
actors out of the way many times getting
to the truth of the story the actors the
writers MA and the director are the
biggest obstacle we are in the way of
what we are trying to achieve let's go
back to the word assumption and the
filter that the director sees this story
from how much does the director really
have to check their own worldview their
own worldview for the filter that they
see the world through which has years of
good things bad things traumas
abandonment happiness of praise how much
do they really have to know themselves
to see am i projecting this worldview
which may not be correct on to every
story okay
first of all how much do they know
themselves yeah and how important it
first of all really important to know
themselves I'm not it's really important
to know themselves I'm sort of
struggling a little bit with how much do
they have to check themselves but let's
go back to notice I think they really
have to know themselves a lot know who
they are I think the more you know who
you are the more you know about your
assumptions your prejudice prejudices
your view of life in the world because
of your life experiences and how you see
things through different filters the
more you know that the better director
you're going to be the more able you may
be to get out of the way your job is to
get out of the way out of the circle and
not try to impose something on a story
or on characters there's a process of
the Travis technique which I don't know
you and I have talked about much at all
called write your life which is it's
it's a very important part of the whole
process which is storytelling and
storytelling not so much writing human
or what's called white your life but
it's autobiographical storytelling
taking a an event in your life and
telling one event in your life maybe
only takes three four five minutes to
tell this event the question is when
you're telling an event in your life can
you tell it honestly if you're telling
something that happened to you this is
what I love about this workshop in this
way of working that event is already
written there's nothing to write it
happened this happened this happened
this happened this is the event that
happened done so there's nothing to
create what what your challenges is how
do I tell this story how do I tell this
story openly and honestly second
question is
do you know yourself well enough you are
the protagonist of that event how well
do you know yourself and how well are
you willing to reveal yourself in all
your flaws and all your courage and all
your trepidations expectations whatever
was going on with you and that event can
you really do you really understand and
can you can you reveal it in the story
knowing that in that event you can tell
it's a little 3-minute event your
journey through that three minute story
is the only thing that the story is
about what happened around you let's say
it was a birthday party that you went to
or something like that some strange
things happen all those things that
happened around you and that impacted
you that's not the story the story is
how you felt how you reacted what you
thought what you were feeling what you
were desiring what you're expecting
that's the story and that's the story of
any character in any movie so going
through right your life can you even do
that how well do you know yourself and
the better you know yourself and can see
how you operate in any moment the better
you're going to be able to see other
characters the better you're going to be
able to work with actors so this whole
thing of knowing yourself is crucial and
this is why we teach write your life to
so many writers directors and actors so
that they can start from a point of
self-awareness and self-revelation
before going into writing the next
script before that taking that next rule
before directing that next movie if you
know yourself you say I now understand
how I operate as a human being you'll
understand every character you work with
so much better so that that is crucial
and then getting back to your question
about imposing your own worldview on it
you will be less likely to do that
because you'll be more likely to want to
honor the view of the characters
and there's one other aspect of this too
is that when you read a script and it
impacts you and I'm assuming you have
the script that you've read that you
want to make it to a movie and you've
been really so moved by it you say I
want to make this my first question to
you the director would be great
why do you want to make this all better
than all that what do you want to say
what do you want to do the best answer
that is I want to create this as a movie
the story as a movie so that viewers
will have the reaction I had to it not
so I can push this message on them I was
so moved by this I was so moved by these
carriage I was touched I was brought to
tears and laughter and I went on an
emotional journey as I was reading this
I want to afford an audience a viewing
audience the same experience knowing
that for each member the audience it'll
be different there won't be exactly the
same as mine so right your life is that
part of the Travis technique yes it's a
part there are three main elements of
the Travis technique one is write your
life which is the autobiographical
storytelling which is besides telling
your own personal stories it's all the
basics of storytelling all the
structural aspects of telling any kind
of story
so it really grounds you in storytelling
and one thing that's important about it
is it's not a writing class per se it's
a story telling can you tell the story
directors writers and actors need to
learn how to tell stories not just write
them writing comes next
can I actually sit down and tell you a
story take three minutes and tell you a
story buy in and then can I examine my
own character within the story no my own
character and can I consciously take you
on a journey through that little three
minute story the when you tell an
autobiographical story the goal is if I
were to tell you our biographical story
right now Karen the goal my goal would
be I'm going to tell it take you through
an event
now take me three to five minutes to
tell you and my goal is to have you
experience while you're listening to the
story exacts exactly what I experienced
as I lived it without having to tell you
oh man that point I was really sad and
all that I don't have to fill that all
in I will tell this story in such a way
that you get it immediately now that's
the power of storytelling whether it's
verbal or Semih
or a play or even a novel to be able to
do this so that's what write your life
is about is it's a very powerful
experience this is why a lot of people
take it over and over and over again
they keep coming back and take it again
take it again it's like going back to
the gym and working out all those
muscles of storytelling again the basics
the other two aspects of the Travis
technique the next one is the
interrogation process would you know
about a little bit which is the
directorial technique of working with
actors to access the characters and it's
a process of not directing the actors
but actually accessing the characters
talking to the characters and how to
stimulate the characters with the
understanding that when you cast
somebody in a movie basically from my
point of view when I cast somebody I'm
saying to that actor the cat character I
want you to play exists already I will
tell the actresses the character exists
already inside you you do not need to
create the character you do not need to
develop the character you don't need to
do anything except think some one thing
that you have to do which is very very
hard to do it's almost impossible you
have to get out of the way and let the
character come out because the character
is inside you and the problem is you're
in the way but I can help you now that's
the interrogation process which helps
the actor actually remove themselves
from the process and above allowed the
character to emerge we can talk more
about that the third part of the Travis
technique is the power of staging
and this all has to do with a very
simple concept that is so powerful that
we all deal with every moment of our
lives we all move in the world and
pretty much the same way all of us we
all move around the world avoiding
conflict seeking comfort even as we set
up to shoot this that's what we did we
we all move in relationship to the
environment and to other people and even
the way we sit and what share we want we
all move that way now this is how we
remove we move in life in response to
all the elements around us the power of
staging is we're creating something
artificial so I can stage a scene in
such a way which I could demonstrate I
could stage a scene in such a way that
how I move the actors in relationship to
each other in relationship to the
environment whatever it is and even in
terms of their own body language I can
move them and actually stimulate within
every actor the emotion I need for the
character at that moment whether its
comfort discomfort anger rage
abandonment whatever it is I can move
them in such a way that that gets
triggered in the actor and the actor now
does not have to create that feeling the
actor has to now struggle with that
feeling as we move through life all of
us we're impacted and we have emotional
reactions to things we can we feel sad
we feel happy we feel abandoned we feel
uncomfortable whatever we have emotional
reactions we don't go through life
trying to create emotions I don't know
of anybody who's ever done that I think
I'm going to be happy in the next second
and I'm you know we don't do that we
would like to have you but we have these
emotional reactions so my goal and it's
very successful working with staging is
I can trigger emotions inside the actor
that are appropriate for the character
and now as the character they have to
struggle with that emotion what to do
with it and now it's authentic you're
not watching an actor create an emotion
or pretend to have an emotion you watch
it watching an actual person strug
or embracing whatever they doing dealing
with genuine emotions and that's the
power of staging and the other aspect of
that is what it's working well the
audience sees it immediately the
audience will react emotionally to so
I'm actually triggering emotions in the
audience simultaneously as I'm doing it
with the act it's like the again getting
back to what we were talking about
before because of projection because
when we watch a scene when we watch a
movie we watch a play we watch anything
even if we watch people in life we
project ourselves into them and we see
two people arguing at another table oh
ho he's so uncomfortable well why are
you reacting that way because you're
saying if I was there this is how I
would be feeling so through staging I
can trigger emotions in the audience and
get help the audience identify more
deeply with the characters so those are
the three elements so when you're doing
a weekend seminar are you beginning with
the writing portion and then working in
interrogation and then doing the staging
or well it's not on a weekend because
it's a great question and it's something
that Elsa and I struggle with all the
time for every workshop we put together
our ideal situation yet we would deal
with all of it but then it's going to
take days or weeks because it's each one
is so massive so what we have is we have
a weekend workshop that we do frequently
which is just called write your life so
you can learn that then we have other
weekend workshops that we've done or
longer which aren't on the interrogation
process that last time we did that it
was actually longer it was 10 days just
for directors just to learn the
interrogation process or will include
the interrogation process and staging
together so it's the Travis technique is
really an umbrella for a lot a lot of
stuff and we have found if we try to
teach too much and it's short period
time then we're skimming over the
surface and we'd like to do workshops
where you can really plunge yourself
into
one technique or one aspect of it to
really benefit from digging that deep
into that process one last question and
then we'll move on in terms of the
writing your life portion what are some
things that you see get in the way of
people telling an authentic version of a
scene from their life I mean do people
tend to paint too rosy of a picture of a
scene that's really from their own life
or the opposite because people tend to
sometimes embellish memories that aren't
they're too dramatic and you can kind of
sense that it's not authentic yeah well
all yeah all of that can happen and
there's more that can happen first of
all we have to look at someone I mean
next time wherever you are you and David
or someplace listening to friends tell a
story just listen and ask yourself
seriously and this is not critical at
all why are they telling the story why
is she telling this story why is he
telling this story you know it there's
there's an agenda there's a reason now
maybe they're telling the story to to
make a point clear that they were trying
to make earlier and they're using the
story to tell it fine maybe they're
telling the story for
self-aggrandizement
maybe they're telling up her they want
sympathy or pity who know there's always
a reason for telling the story and the
sense it's an autobiographical story
lots of times the reason to tell the
story is for you I want to tell the
story so you understand something about
me so I'm doing it for me I'm trying to
elicit something out of you what we do
in write your life is say can you tell
the story and think of the story as a
gift I want to give you a gift the gift
is the experience you're going to go
through hearing the story has nothing to
do with me in a way even though it's my
story because when we make a film when
we tell a story that's a gift to the
world
I don't want I make a movie I don't want
people to be thinking about me the
director none at all
I want them involved in the story the
gift and the gift of the story whether
it's told or it's a film the gift
the story is twofold one is what the
viewer or listener is experiencing as
the story is being on for unfolding
that's one gift those two hours in the
movie or just five minutes listen your
story that's one gift the other gift
which is even bigger in a way is the
legacy of the story we've all seen
movies that we will never forget we've
all seen movies that have changed our
lives in certain ways and sometimes
we're not even aware of it until years
later we go oh that Wow's when I saw
that movie something shipped that's the
power of what we're doing and that's
also the gift of storytelling that it
can last forever
and again it's not about the storyteller
so getting back to your question what
are the traps they can fall into is are
you doing this so you tell your story so
that the listener will see you in a
different way well that's then it's all
about Julie you're doing this for
self-aggrandizement or something else
I'm not are you willing this is a big
question or a chelate are you willing to
tell the story and reveal really how
vulnerable you were how stupid you were
how arrogant you were which means how
human you were at that time can you do
that and that's not asking for pity in
other words how honest can you be so
what we focus on in the right your life
can you tell it honestly get the agenda
out of the way your agenda now is be
honest and that's what a lot of people
struggle with they struggle first of all
looking at what was really going on when
they start to see it it gets a little
shaky and then reveal it it gets even
shaky and I said well that's the
business were in we're storytellers and
we don't tell stories for people to
change their opinion about us we
actually spell tell stories so people
can have an experience that may shift
something within them and maybe even
change their opinion about themselves
not about us we have to tell these
stories
honestly authentically we the director
writer and actors actually have to this
is really ironic because we are the
primary that's the guy called the golden
triangle director actors or writers
that's the Golden Triangle that's
telling the story the rest of it is a
support system we as that golden
triangle the primary triangle of telling
stories have to get out of the way we
have to remove ourselves from the very
thing we're doing which is very hard
it's not about the writer it's not about
the director and it's certainly not
about the actors it's about the
characters we have to get out of the way
and serve the story and serve the
characters and that's hard mark I
believe you said that every director
must also be a writer
so does that mean that every director
should rewrite in some sense the
screenplay of the movie that they're
directing what a great question to
question you always hit me with two
questions first of all every director
I'm going to do every director should be
a writer yes every director should write
whether they write well or not is not
important I think every director should
understand the writing process that's
why we do write your life but also the
screenwriting process which is different
but and to at least understand and
appreciate the challenges I'm trying to
get a story into what I call you know
the to our haiku you know it's like
reducing it down to the story to those
elements and we can talk about that
later but in terms of the director
rewriting no rewriting the script that
Gretchen gets a script it's not the
director's job to rewrite it is the
director's job to work with the writer
I'm a very passionate protector of the
writer and I think if the writer has
brought a script to a point where a
director is interested in doing it then
they should keep working with the writer
I don't understand this getting rid of
writers or bringing in other people to
rewrite I do understand the
collaboration of a director and writer
working together and then eventually
with the actors and everybody else
staying involved when I've done films
the writer stays all the way through the
whole making of the film all the way
through production and post-production
they are part of the storytelling team I
have my job they have
their job I like having the writer on
the set I'm shooting something there was
one film I was doing which we were
having trouble with a scene I remember
this note the two writers were there is
a fighting team and we couldn't get it
to work and I told him I said I'm going
to improvise the scene hold on
they went okay and I went back to the
actors and I took them through a process
quick process and then we said improvise
the scene and I remember the writers
going yes you got it no the fact that
the writers said yes that's where we're
going I felt great it wasn't me
rewriting the scene it wasn't even the
actors rewriting the scene the the
writers were there I'm trying to serve
their initial vision of the film
combined with mine combined with the
actors of trying to reach the characters
so I don't I don't like the idea
although it happens a lot in Europe
which you may know and I've run I have a
lot of friends because I teach a lot in
Europe especially in Germany and a lot
of friends who were very very successful
writers there and it's a constant
problem they will write a script say for
television the director comes on and the
director doesn't rewrite the first thing
they do is they rewrite it I was at at
one point I've directed a little bit in
Germany and I was one point was going to
direct something and the production
company said sent me the script I said
okay they said when are we going to get
your directors script and I said what do
you mean I'm reading the script so yes I
want to do so when they were gonna so
what he lead the director script what
they meant was we expect you to rewrite
it now so this was the producers
expecting the director to rewrite the
script that they had bought and they
wanted to produce and I said no I'm not
going to rewrite it I'm going to work
with the writer so I don't encourage
directors to think they have to rewrite
it I've seen too many times especially
in Europe directors rewriting and
reworking a script and it was really
clear what they were doing unconsciously
I think or maybe
consciously they were creating a script
that they knew how to direct and by
doing that they reduced it or shifted it
from the initial intention rather than
trying to serve the script that was
there initially they altered it to
something that they could handle
and then the story lost its essence
becomes a lawsuit okay lost this is what
there's one very important project which
a friend of mine had written and she had
a powerful script and it was changed so
dramatically into the style of film that
the director felt comfortable in doing
he had been hired to do a film that he
wasn't really comfortable with so he
changed it into something and it changed
totally had lost to me the essence of
what was there originally it turned out
fine at the end but it was a whole
different it's a different story it
wasn't what was there originally what is
the most critical thing that a director
should do when reading and reviewing a
script okay good question and this is
one of the hardest things to do and I
can tell you as a director it's really
very difficult you get a script you
starting to read it and then we're
assuming before you start reading it's
something that you're being asked to
consider to direct or along those lines
this may be something you're going to
work on or not let's assume that you are
the most difficult thing to do while
reading it is to not direct it now I can
tell you as a director I start reading
something and I see directorial problems
immediately or directorial opportunities
immediately like oh I know I could cast
in that role or I know where we could
shoot suddenly my mind is directing my
mind is figuring out how to get this
thing that I'm reading which I haven't
finished reading yet up onto the screen
and I haven't given the story a chance
to impact me I have taken a side street
the hardest thing to do is sit down can
I sit down with this story which happens
to be a script but it's a story in
script
and can I just read it and emotionally
respond to it just respond like we all
do when we go to see a movie
hopefully we sit down and just respond
it's going to be my first and only time
I get to do this without knowing the
story
so my response the first time through is
really crucial so what I suggest to a
lot of directors to do and this is in
one of my books directing feature films
thing I call the script wash can you sit
down with a script take a script nothing
written in it to accept the script
itself no none of your notes read it and
as you're reading it and as you're
responding it can you note what your
response is not your directing I your
reader I your audience I when you're
moved when you feel sad when you feel
confused when you feel intrigued Wow
what's going to happen to him oh this
isn't interesting Oh idea wasn't
expecting that in other words can you
note and I'm seriously I mean it
seriously write it in right in there
what you're thinking and feeling as
you're going through the script as
you're responding to the characters as
you're responding to the events even it
doesn't make sense I don't understand
why they're doing this and maybe three
pages later how I get it that's a
response that's an audience's response
to the story can you do that you need to
do that because basically in the making
of the film that's what you're expecting
the audience to do you have to create
something that they're going to do that
and this your emotional journey through
the film is sort of a guide for where
you want to do it actually what you want
as since you can only make the film for
one person you you want to create
something on the screen that now does
the same thing to you now as that
scripted the first time you read it
that's your goal it sounds like you're
meditating on the script you know
there's a term monkey mind
in meditation so it sounds almost like
the monkey mind is the directors voice
in your in your ear and you've got to
get rid of that yes you have to in this
it also applies to actors producers
anybody else
everybody starts shifting into their
role actors are reading oh I could do
that well I don't know how I would
suddenly as an actor you're not giving
the story a chance to impact you you're
not giving those characters a chance
you're getting you are getting in the
way so your your right is sort of
meditative shutting up the monkey mind
shutting down the director actor
producer writer voice in your head and
just allowing allow yourself like a
meditation allow yourself to just
respond to what's coming to you can you
do that it's really really hard I would
imagine it would almost prove someone to
not be at home it sounds like to read
something in another setting because
they'd be too distracted is that
something you advise or to get out of
their own way but if you're at home and
then you see oh the cat's water needs
changing or differently you're not going
to be in the story possibly yeah I think
that's a great idea I think as an
individual you have to say where can I
under what circumstances can I
experience this script as purely as
possible okay now I'll tell you one way
this is really so sound weird but it can
work have somebody read it to you and
now you're not reading now you're
listening now you're hearing a story
told now that may work better for you if
I said to Elsa if I said I wish I can
just read this scene to me now I'm
hearing it I'm I just want to get it I
want it to come at me in a different way
and so do you have a list of let's say
emotional words that you want to jot
down so that you're getting out of the
director aka monkey mind and jotting
down the emotional language sort of I'm
sort of I don't know if they're
emotional words there's a shorthand that
I
have when I read a script that I
understand I can tell you what one one
thing if I'm reading and something
doesn't make sense one word will do it I
write in really with a question mark
go critically you're going to go that
that's what's gonna now that's so that
that's that's me tracking where my mind
so next time I'm reading through it and
I go I can see right there I had that
questions right there I had confusion or
disconnection or disassociation not I'm
not saying this is good or bad that's
just what I did what I did someone else
may not or I may read it again and go oh
yeah I can see why I did that but now I
can see it's not a problem whatever and
I may have a different relationship to
it another way to do it let's say I read
a script and Elsa hasn't read it and I
may say let me tell you the story now
I'm going to tell it I'm not going to
read it to her I will tell her this
story in fact we did this the other day
I started to tell her this now my
telling of the story now I'm in a
storytelling mode and I'm trying to I'm
focusing on taking her on a journey
through it I'm not really directing it
and I'm getting her response so that
that's another relationship I get back
to the story I'm not in the process of
directing at all I'm trying to stay as
close to the story to understand and I
think the most difficult thing we have
is I have a script my job eventually I
can't do it on the first reading my job
eventually is to understand where the
writer was coming from what the writer
was intending to do and I really can't
get that to that without talking to the
writer eventually but with prior to that
with the script wash I have to establish
my relationship to the story my
fascination for or my intern what I'm
intrigued with what I'm confused about I
have to get my relationship in place and
then go to the writer and then stuck
understand where he or she
he was coming from even why she wrote
the story what she was trying to say
what she wanted to say why this
character why is this woman the
protagonist all I see well that's what
other words I have to get back to their
source not just the script again this
gets back to assumption we were talked
about before I can follow into the trap
of a son assuming this is what she was
trying to do I can't tell you the number
of times I've read a script and it's
very clear I can make an assumption I
think I know what the writer is trying
to do here what the writers trying this
story I try and tell and I meet and talk
with a writer I was so wrong I was so on
now they did they tell the story that
they wanted to know not at all is the
story they wanted to tell interesting
absolutely did I miss it I totally
missed it but let's go back to the
source that's the story you want to tell
okay there was a lot of things in here
that are off-track the story they want
to tell is way more important than the
story they have told and we're trying to
bring those two together so that's the
that's the danger of assumption and if I
start directing in my mind before I've
even had that conversation I'm not done
on a track the dimension of writers
could say no no that's not what I wanted
and the reason I've made a mistake is I
didn't check to see really where the
writer was coming from so you do the
script wash you you read it for a sort
of emotional effect you talk to the
writer and then at what point do you
then turn on the directors mind and say
okay now I'm reading the script with an
intentional directors mind turned on I
would say first of all um the directors
mind sort of starts to seep in pretty
early and as I said before it's hard to
keep it quiet because that director mind
wants to direct it's a very eager little
puppy in there going we have a script we
have a story let's make it the dirt
during that the process of working with
the writer the directors mind is working
it's working a lot because I can hear
from the right of what he or she is
trying to do the story they're trying to
tell and my directive mine is now
thinking okay how can I facility
that or what's in the way of that or how
can we explain that or does this mean we
need another scene now I'm sort of
writing a little bit but I'm not writing
and or I can hear what the writer wants
I go okay that's a great idea
I have no idea how to get that on the
screen it's a great idea but that just
doesn't seem feasible to do that so now
I have to talk to the writer and
actually say that now the director mine
is working because the director down
here down the stream and saying we've
got a problem trying to make this let's
see if we can solve that here with the
writer so the directors mind is working
rather soon once we get to a script that
I feel is very strong I'm confident
about it although it's not the final
draft as you probably know the final
draft of the script is when the picture
is locked at the end and because the
script is always shifting because it's
an organic entity but once we get to the
point where we think we can go into
productions and really consider what the
producers were going into production now
the directors mind is really working a
lot and now it has to start to take over
because now the directorial process is
moving forward now I'm thinking about
thinking more about even though I've
thought about it before being about
casting and I'm thinking about locations
and elements and the team that I want to
put together to help tell this story but
I have to make sure that I have a script
that is the strongest I believe we can
do by we I mean myself
the writer producers whoever else is
involved at that time there could be a
lot of people they're all they're all
involved but we've got the best we can
do knowing it's going to change and
believing that the change will only be
for the better whatever it is then then
I can start to take over there's the
director and start making demands and
and influencing that from the directors
playing a deal let's assume there's a
heart and soul for every screenplay and
if that's the case how does a director
find that the heart and soul of the
screenplay
ah I would say yeah there is a heart and
soul for the story and hopefully it's in
the screenplay the in the writ there's a
reason I make that distinction is
because many times it's a very strong
story in the screenplay which is
screenplay which is basic a step in a
process of bringing it to a film the
screenplay hasn't really captured that
so listen at the story there's a heart
and a soul and the story and that I
think in discussion with the writer or
writers whoever they are that's the
first thing you've got to find and it's
like Elsa and I had a consultation just
yesterday on a script and with the
writers and what we were looking for
it's just what you're talking about that
what's the heart and soul of this it's a
really interesting screenplay it's a
thriller action invention thriller but
what is at the heart of it that the
audience can grab onto and identify with
my feeling is the audience doesn't
really want to watch a big
action-adventure film what they want I
mean to watch it be thrilled to watch it
one that's well-done but they want to
connect with the people and what the
people's journey is or what the people's
struggles are or what the people's
epiphanies are or disappointments are in
the transformation of characters that's
what they want to they want to connect
with the aspect of that story that
relates to their own lives which may be
very subtle only very very powerful but
we have to identify that so talking with
these these two writers yesterday that
was the goal is to find that and then
once we can identify that with the
writers then we could eat all of us can
ask YouTube is it in the script is it
clear in the script that that's what it
is but first of all you got to feel what
it is and that's why many times looking
at a script you can feel it's not there
but rather than trying to cover it up or
pretend it's there or soon and it's
there or just insert something that go
back to the writers go back to the
people who had the original idea
and find out what that is and then try
to identify that and that is actually
for a director that's what's going to
guide you through the entire rest of the
process that's what the movie is all
about this movie is all about this
character who is fighting these
struggles was in fighting these aspects
of himself in the world around him and
his family or his work or whatever he's
fighting and that what gets revealed
through that process is what this man or
this woman is going through that we can
identify with so you got to get that
early then the process of the rewrites
re-examining the script is how can we
get that in how can we make that clear
to the audience also clear to the actors
really important so the actors can see
if the actors were playing this part can
attach themselves to that so if it's not
clear is it because we're not having an
emotional response to it or we're not
having the emotional response that the
writer intended us to have I'll probably
both when I hear it emotional response
or the one that's intended or the one
that's assumed by the writer okay this
is this is a danger of writing this is
getting back to that assumption thing
we're talking about before which we deal
a lot with I'm going to go back to write
your life I'm telling you a story about
a traumatic experience I had it's for
instance say personal experience and I'm
going to assume that if I tell you
everything that happened you're going to
have the same emotional reaction I did
that's a huge assumption you play not a
writer can write a script
it may be true may be personal may be
totally fiction but the right of writing
that script and all those characters is
having an emotional experience as he or
she is creating it with these characters
how they're relating to each other all
the twists and turns in the story and
echoing oh that's great that's great
assuming that anybody else reading it
will be having the same reaction that
may not be true so that the assumption
of the writer is a problem can be a
problem the best way to deal with that
is really simple you tell the writer
there's your problem
you wrote that scene and you're very
moved by it I read the scene I don't get
it okay
what you're intending is great I'm not
getting it now other people are not
you're assuming they were getting it
because you are so identified with those
characters in that situation okay not a
problem let's figure out how we can make
it clearer to the artist so the audience
does get it and that's my job as a
director that's my job as a directing
consultant or a writing consultant is to
help writers get to that point where the
scene is clear and note one thing which
we don't need to talk a lot about but
one thing is a script
speaking of script and writer a script
initially in order to get made into a
movie has to engage the reader and as
you know the reader very often is not
the person who's going to produce it the
reader is somebody down the line and
some production company whatever it does
you in other words that script by itself
by its little self those 120 pages has
to impact that reader so the first thing
is let's make sure the reader gets it
the reader who just picks up another
script and starts reading gets it that's
really crucial
so forget me the director and forget all
the other people we got it we've got to
make sure that the script is strong
enough that that works and if it's not
doing that then it's not going to get
made and the writer can deal with his
for his or her frustration like why
can't they get it don't go there don't
go why can't they get it let's go back
to how good this is what a lot of people
like Michael Haig and Chris Lowell and
all those people teach screenwriting
work with writers on and not lots of
times it's not about what the story is
about how do you craft these scenes and
characters and certainly that the writer
will get it and eventually all the other
people who are going to work on it so
then the writer needs to know their
assumptions and their lenses that they
see the world through as well yes yes
exactly that's why a lot of writers take
write your life to start to see that
you're right that those lenses as you
toggle those filters that you're looking
and the assumption is a fill
and looking through that well you know I
I had this um I'm just gonna make this
up I had this bout with cancer and I
fought off cancer at Eglin robbed me of
a year of my life but now I'm a cancer
survivor and I can tell you about it and
you should feel horrified by what
happened because I did in frightened and
someone could tell me that I go okay
it's not it's not going to impact me the
way you think it is only because you as
you tell it we re experienced everything
you went through so that filter of
assumption the filter of assumption of a
writer even writing fiction I created
this great moment in the scene and
nobody gets it well and we have to keep
working on it I understand what you're
going for I understand what you want
them to get you haven't crafted in a way
for them to get it so it's also
understanding not only a limit writers
point of view not only understanding
their lair or a barrier of assumption
and because every screen would I just
think this is really true finishes the
screenplay thinks it's brilliant
hopefully they do why otherwise why do
it and that's an assumption too but also
they have to realize that every reader
has barriers against certain things that
you have to plow through you have to
break through you have to Surprise them
you have to sort of find your way around
the barriers and the obstacles that the
reader has within themselves so yes you
have to understand yourself and you have
to understand you can't say why don't
you get that you have to understand that
they don't get it for a reason what's
the biggest mistake a filmmaker can make
before day one on a movie set before day
one day one of shooting uh-huh
Wow okay I mean let me think on that
firstly the biggest mistake like I'm not
showing up
well this support performer but you
would not you narrow it down to before
day one in other words before they go
into production something maybe they
overlooked something they sort of
micromanage that shouldn't have been
micromanage I don't know and I don't
know and in terms of over
ding something a micromanaging now we're
down to details and it could be there
could be a lot of things but I think one
of the biggest mistakes a director can
make and one that I've made frequently
way too up is assuming that I know what
I want
assuming I'm talking about for the whole
movie and every scene every moment
really convinced I know exactly what I
want and know I do know what I want but
what I'm talking about is the assumption
that that is that is what eventually I
will want in the film
in other words closing my mind is
something beyond that other than that I
think the biggest thing that director
has to do is keep their mind open to the
two possibilities beyond what they've
imagined even no matter how much they've
rehearsed it no matter how much they've
worked on the script no matter all the
preparation that they're doing is it
going into production keep your mind
open one thing that's very important in
the whole filmmaking process and I'm
going to talk about now just working
with actors for a second I'm going to go
way back and actors who come in and for
an audition okay our actors looking for
a job wanting a job needing job whatever
actors once they're cast your actors are
cast and now they're cast and but you
haven't hit production yet are now a
different breed of animal totally they
are actors who have a job and so they
and you'll notice that it's really
interesting after you cast the movie and
then you're bringing the actors together
maybe for the first reading they are
totally different they're not this the
same sort of needy compliant careful
people they're a little arrogant they're
a little full of themselves though
they're a little different everyone has
changed in a slightly different way
they're not quite the same people and it
can be sort of horrifying like did I get
the right people here because they're
different now okay so now you're in the
rehearsal process and all that nib and
you're going through that and you
aiming going you're in pre-production
and you're going towards production okay
and you're rehearsing whatever you're
doing which we can talk about later then
you hit production they change again and
so now it's the person who walks on the
set and they know today is the day we're
shooting that scene they are under
enormous pressure so there are three
different stages so as you go into
production getting back to your question
be aware that these people have a shift
look different now they may be more
problematic they may be more compliant
they may be more irritating they may be
more charming who knows what they're
going to be but they're human and
they're under enormous pressure now so
they will try to shift to their places
of comfort and all that so but again
getting back to your question about the
mistakes you can make keep your mind
open these people these actors under
enormous pressure now who you've worked
with however much you work with them who
knows what they're going to come up with
who knows how that's seen that you just
rehearsed three weeks ago that you
thought was so wonderful in the
rehearsal room and now you're going to
shoot it it's going to shift it's going
to change because the actors have
changed keep your mind open ideally this
goes back to the rehearsal process and
all that which we haven't talked about
but ideally if you've been rehearsing
deeply enough and profoundly enough
ideally those actors are going to go
even deeper on you because that's
pressure they will go deeper into the
character and they will start revealing
stuff to you that you had probably never
imagined don't try to make the movie in
production that you had thought you were
making in pre-production it's going to
shift it's going to change ideally if
the process that you've been going
through a bit working on the film has
been to go for the depth of characters
it's going to get deeper it's going to
get better but you have to be flexible
and like you can show up and suddenly
they're doing that scene in a way you
never imagined now you have a problem
not because they're doing it different
what do you do do you try to get them
back to what you had before or you let
them go they were there going okay this
is in other words don't assume that you
have to try to keep it to what you are
thinking before there's a chapter or
section of my book and production that I
call the nightly reconsideration process
which is very simply this you read the
script you imagine a movie you cast it
and all that now you're on
pre-production and you're working on
rehearsal and putting together all the
elements and the movie and your
imagination is getting more detailed but
it's shifting it's shifting from what it
was when you first read it now it's
coming into some kind of perceived
reality although it's not really there
yet now you're in production and as you
start production the entire movie is in
your head to some degree you can see it
you can feel it you know what you're
going for you shoot the first scene I
can guarantee you that scene will not
turn out the way you thought it was
going to like I can go into you for
everything you do to it won't turn out
exactly the way you thought but the
nightly reconsideration process is on
that first day so you shoot two scenes
one scene two seems suddenly you have
shot some material that is going to be
in your movie that scene has now been
defined by what you shot the
possibilities the range of it it's been
limited actually down to what you shot
it hasn't been expanded it's been
limited and now because that exists used
it's automatically you start
reconsidering the entire movie
well that scenes playing that way then
oh then it's going to stop it it's a
living growing thing and so every night
you aren't reconsidering the entire
movie well she was white she was tougher
than that that I thought she was going
to be and well if that's the way oh my
god is it going to go that way how do I
want it to go now so you've got to keep
your eyes open because the characters
are now the characters are
how determining where your movie is
going not you sounds like then plan but
be open plan but be open ok yes have yes
have a good plan have a strong but have
a definite plan that what you are
convinced will work and then be flexible
be willing to throw it out but we're
willing to adapt it adjust it so how do
you work with directors who get so
married to that plan that they they just
can't deviate from it because that's how
they saw it and they know their vision
is you just just trust me on this and
this is going to work we've just got to
do it this way okay this is a plan in
terms of shooting the film certainly
film but with the scene with the actors
with visuals or what what aspect okay
with with an actor and let's say the
actor was one way in the audition and
one way in the read brought a good level
of emotion and then you get them on set
and they've kind of retracted into a
little bit of a shell but it's working
in some ways but not the way you
envisioned it because you can still play
the scene but they're going to be a
little more awkward and introverted not
maybe more emotional how you one of them
to be okay
okay so there's been an adjustment
within performance um that you may not
have asked for but it's there right and
you're saying that it's good it's
interesting but it's not what you wanted
or thought you wanted say back in
rehearsal in pre-production and now
you're shooting no I didn't and so what
do you do what do you do because even
though yeah it looks good and I like in
other people the other actors are
feeding off the energy ice it's got to
be this one way okay the first thing is
the idea it's got to be this one way is
a trap watch out for that because I can
tell you right now as a director - a
director this idea of while you're
shooting knowing precisely what you want
and you're going for that is a problem
not a problem going for it but it's a
problem believing that if you have that
then you're fine
because I know exactly when you'll know
what you want from that character and
that scene and that's in post-production
in post-production when you're editing
that scene together and this has
happened many many times I've seen it
way too many times you edit the scene
together you go okay it looks good looks
good got it then you put the whole movie
together and now that scene isn't
looking so good anymore because it's
part of a stream a movie is not a bunch
of scenes linked together it's a stream
it's a constant movement it's a constant
movement of characters and now there's
suddenly these two characters hitting
that scene and something is off now
maybe it's too restrained maybe it's too
enthusiastic maybe it's something
there's something that's tipping
something wrong now so the big question
now when post-production that scene
isn't quite working what options do you
have to fix the scene because I can tell
you and again I've seen this many times
at that moment you go I know what I need
but I don't have it we didn't shoot it
that way we didn't shoot it where she's
more restrained and we didn't shoot it
where he's more adamant we didn't shoot
it where the emotions has more conflict
we didn't shoot it with the more sense
of sympathy or empathy on whatever
whatever you think you never had that
we'd be great so the question really
becomes why didn't you shoot that the
reason you didn't shoot that is because
you didn't think that's what you needed
even if someone had suggested even if I
had been on the set with the director
and that this has happened a few times I
said are you sure you don't want to do
one more where she's a little more
restrained or one more wishes which is a
little bit more out of control or try
one the slight difference no no no I'm
fine since I here I'm fine I just can
feel that chills like oh because you
don't know no major X as I told them you
don't know so a lot of directors I work
with will if I'm with them I say you
sure you want to do that it'll take less
time to shoot that than it would be to
argue it
so I say shoot it now this comes back to
Robert Altman okay Robert Altman who I
knew for a while
and when I was in New York he was
directing a play they're working it
played that my wife at the time was in
called come back to the five-and-dime
Jimmy Dean Jimmy Dean Robert Ullman is a
obviously a master film director
independent film director who had done
theater before if I can done another
play with another friend of mine Frank
salty Dan play with his so he knew about
theater but now he's doing a big
Broadway show and because my wife was in
it I was allowed to come in and sit in
on rehearsals and I was at there at one
time now Robert Altman has like a
six-week rehearsal period which is
typical you know is about to is about
halfway through it and he had the whole
play staged he had tried a lot of
different things and you could see he
was going I don't know what to do next I
don't know what to do next now I being
the arrogant person that I am and sort
of cynical said to him well one thing
you could do is try all the things you
know won't work
he says it's great let's okay so he
started doing the craziest things let's
try it this way
now this is theater and being my
background being theater this is what we
do it's here we try things that don't
work we tried things
nassim ridiculous way outside the box
and he started playing with and the
actors loved it and all that but the
important thing is what he said later he
said to me as I get it the rehearsal
process in theater is the same as the
editing process in film now when he said
that first I didn't quite get it and I
thought about it and went wait a minute
he's right the rehearsal process in
theater is a process of trial and error
experimentation let's try this doesn't
work let's try that all that work let's
keep that lets and even in terms of
script you can be changing things until
you can keep changing so it's a trial
and error period leading up to opening
night and eventually
you narrow it down to this we're going
to play it this way and even then day
before you open you could be trying
things the editing process is a similar
process it's trial and error let's cut
it together this way let's try it this
way let's try it with this moment let's
try cutting the scene this way but the
thing is the difference between theater
and film in post-production film if you
don't have the material you need to go
through a trial and error process you
can't do it you look at that actresses
performance and say I've got four takes
of her doing it every time she did it
she did it pretty much the same way
that's all I've got
so you don't have the choice my
recommendation to every director I work
with this is the way I shoot stuff my
job impotent not post-production my job
in production is to create the range of
material from which I will choose later
I don't have any way to do it I have a
rate now I have in my mind I know what I
want but I also want a range of material
way beyond that sometimes the most
ridiculous thing and the actors know
that fact I tell the actors I don't know
how I want this to play I don't even
know how I want the entire movie to play
they say you don't know so we're going
to keep experimenting we're going to
shoot a lot of rehearsals we're going to
catch it and the actors relax they go oh
the pressure is off I'm not trying to
hit a perfect performance because Mark
doesn't know what it is I said no I
don't know what it is I'll tell you what
I think it could be I could be wrong so
even this last thing I shot just a few
weeks ago and I said to the actors and I
always do this I said okay let's do a
few more just for you be outrageous I
asked the act the acts be outrageous go
way outside the box as far as you want
and we shoot that and some of that stuff
is amazing and we use it had no idea
this is staying open but it's going into
post-production without this range of
material out of which myself and the
editor can start to create the scene as
you know in a film the scene is not
created when you're shooting it the
scene is created in post-production and
we will create a scene
that never happened it never happened
that three minutes scene never was
played that way
unfurl that is but that that three
minutes is made up about seven or eight
different performances so there is no
perfect performance and that scene is
cut in relationship to the rest of the
movie and I need that range of material
in order to do that it almost sounds
like a new director would have more of
that mindset where I have to get it is
specifically this way but then ones that
sat in an editing Bay and have seen and
been the position of I don't have any
filler and I can't change it around
yes and this is why some of the best
directors we have and you just recently
when we're off-camera you mentioned who
you mentioned Sidney Lumet all right
Stanley Kubrick's a lucubra Cassavetes
has a very hot Bergman who all worked in
theater now directors who've worked in
theater understand this process
absolutely cuz he'll that's my process
my process is rehearsal trial and error
rehearsal trial now not trying to nail
something down before I'm done it's all
trial and error and so the directors
understanding that process and this is
why when I consult with directors I take
them through what we call a workshopping
process I take them through with their
film this trial and error process even
before pre-production with actors so
they can start to see how this can work
they can see the range of possibilities
and get out of their mind getting back
to your question but releasing from
their mind doesn't a feeling that really
releasing from their mind the feeling or
the belief that they know how the movie
should be played that's not important
like that's a trap I know how this scene
should be played that's a trap better
way to think about a scene is I know how
I want this scene to hit me emotionally
I know that which goes back to the
script wash I know how I want to be hit
by the scene
I have no idea how I'm going to get
there and it's going to be trial and
error right up into the last edit until
I can look at it that's it
it's doing it it's doing it it's doing
it to me the scene that I was just
talking about that
I recently shot a shift in the music
that the editor came up with a slight
shift that he did he did a miraculous
thing and this was a scene that I was
directing and I was directing it for in
front of a group of directors that was
talking about earlier that came from
overseas for this workshop demonstrating
all these techniques but the scene in
the editing was shifted dramatically
this is really interesting in terms of
the trial and error as the editor was
cutting together he picked a piece of
music he thought would be interesting on
the scene I liked it we changed the Edit
which means the Edit now that piece of
music didn't fit anymore and he took it
out in Elgin I went oh no we want to
keep that in but we but there was
another piece of music we wanted to come
right after two different pieces of
music by the same composer same artist
well they don't fit together at all and
we can can't we keep that one in and put
that one in it goes no no you can't it
won't work
but he as an editors knew that we wanted
to do that and by actually manipulating
the second piece of the music changing
the key that it was in he made a mint
good to go and suddenly the scene
started working again
now that's trial and error
that's the editing process now that was
just a piece of music has nothing to do
with the performances and it was
suddenly it underlined what was going on
in the performances and so you have to
keep their mind open to all these
possibilities constantly one of my
favorite quotes is from Sydney
who I know a little bit when he said
it's a making movies is great I love the
process and making noises this is only
one problem I have to understand Sydney
came from theatre too and worked with
Sanford Meisner and all that
he says there's only one problem with
making eventually you have to show it to
somebody which really means eventually
you have to stop the process of making
the movie the process of making a movie
is great but when you have to lock
things down and go that's it
that's the hard part that's the most
painful part mark in your book the film
directors bag of tricks I think I
noticed that you wrote something about
director Elia Kazan and how he would get
to know actors and take them out to
dinner and really find out about their
story have you done that with actors do
you feel that it's very crucial in terms
of getting the most from that character
you know and finding out what lenses
they're seeing everything what
assumptions yeah I think yeah I think
yeah getting to know the actors is
crucial like there are a lot of maybe
not a lot and for several directors who
even say they don't need to read the
actors they just need to meet them and
get to know them before they can but I
think like what really because then
would do a lot of directors do again
coming out of theater these are people
commodity we get to know the actors
personally remember when you're casting
and somebody an actor comes in and reads
for you and let's say he just reads one
scene all you know at that moment is how
well he can read that scene that's all
you know now maybe did it beautifully
maybe it was very impressive but you
know nothing beyond that and what one of
the things you don't know you don't know
anything about him or her so this is
someone you're considering casting yes
get to know them some directors I've
worked with Italy even invite three or
four actors back for callback and never
read them we just sit around and talk
with them and discuss things and just to
get to know that the personality you got
to get to know who these people are how
they think
remember if you cast them you're going
to spend a long time with them and
you're not spending a long time with
them just reading that part you're
spending a long time with that person
and you need to establish a relationship
with them how you can work with them how
they think what they
leaving and important part of say taking
an actor to lunch or something they need
to get to know you you need to be just
as open and available and vulnerable to
them as you want them to be to you
because then you're creating a safe
space for within which they can work
they need to know that you are there and
you are willing to become as vulnerable
and that's open and as available as they
are as you want them to be okay so let's
say you've you've met the factor you've
had coffee with them whatever you've had
them read they're great for the part
then they show up on set and they're not
as open they're a little more closed off
okay I have a question for you sure
between meeting them and casting them
and then you jump to now they show up on
the set why has there been any rehearsal
in between sure there's been rehearsal a
baby but maybe during rehearsal they
were good and you felt that they they
brought what the character needed but
then they show up on set and they're
closed off okay let's assume that's been
rehearsal which we haven't talked about
yet but there's been rehearsal and
interrogation act and we're in good
shape now we go to they show up in the
set and they're closed off and my job
very very important job at this point is
to unjust try to understand why and I
can tell you right now why generally why
the actors closed off something's wrong
something they're afraid of fear it's
usually a fear based something is in the
way now it can be some actors just get
closed off because we're shifting into
production like we talked about before
that shift it could be fear of making
usually fear up I'm not going to do a
job I'm going to make a mistake
something's going to go wrong and so
they they will retreat within themselves
this is very normal it's very natural
it's nothing to be worried about but it
is something to be dealt with you have
to deal with it and I can tell you the
best way to deal with it is to actually
ignore it
because if you start talking about it
you can own very possibly make it worse
what are you afraid of oh it's just a
camera's and you know you're talking
about the fear and it'll just get bigger
that's all you have to do the best way
to deal with it is ignore it honor it
but ignore it and go into the
interrogation process if I start
shifting with that actor and start
talking to the character do you know
what happens to that fear it goes into
the background with the actor as I
allowed the actor to shift into the
background and pull the character into
the foreground okay the fear that the
actor has goes with the actor doesn't
stay with the character the actor will
probably feel very comfortable just
being the character you don't want the
actor to drag that fear or whatever the
concern is into the character that's
what you have to avoid and through the
interrogation process you can actually
stop it before that happens you know you
would talked in your video about
sometimes when you push up against
something for so long it becomes this
obstacle that you can't defeat after a
while and maybe I'm butchering what you
said but I find that a fascinating
concept so can you talk about how that
happens and interest a metaphorical
sense well yeah I mean yeah in that
video talking about pushing up against
an obstacle something that's resisting
you it and I believe what you're
referring to is I'm talking about a
character doing that not so much an
actor or the director but a character
doing that which is pretty much the same
thing as an actor jerk and then what we
do all of us will do if we're pushing up
against something and this seems to be
no way to get around it and we can't
make any progress we will do what I call
an adjustment we will shift from where
we are and try to pursue the same
objective from a different angle words
in other words change our attitude
change our modus operandi change our
plans right somebody wants to be an
actor really want something I can't get
any work can't can they work and say
okay I'll move to New York there's an
adjustment it may or may not work I
don't know
those we will make an adjustment to get
around it
now this discussion we're having now
came out of actors dealing with fears or
being a problem and if you're pushing up
against an actor and they're a problem
and you have a problem with an actor and
they're being resistant or being with
withholding or whatever if you keep
pushing up against that problem and keep
pushing it'll probably get stronger and
so the thing is make a shift
interrogation is one way to make a shift
going for a walk with the actor maybe
the ships in let's get out let's get out
here let's get out the set how am I
supposed to be shooting yeah but I'm the
director guess well I read everybody
does what I want to do I've done this
let's go for a walk where we're going I
don't know you want to get a cup of
coffee and suddenly they're going okay
that's a shift let's approach this in a
different way take the pressure off can
you do something differently rather than
just pushing against it mark let's talk
about the interrogation let's talk about
the beginnings of it how you begin to
use it with an actor how you came up
with the idea the interrogation process
that I use with actors is not something
I quote came up with it's something I
literally discovered um during a very
long process I've been working as a
director for 30 40 years something like
that I lose track of how many years and
it's one of those things that I look
back over my career and I realize what
I've been doing I didn't realize this
until maybe 10 years ago what I've been
doing I've been constantly in a process
of experimentation in directing
experimentation working with actors an
experimentation that has headed the core
a very simple question there must be a
better way to do this there's got to be
another way there are a lot of great
ways of doing this now when you think
about what we're doing which we talked
about before we're all storytellers
directors writers and actors are all
storytellers and our goal as I see it is
to tell stories as honestly truthfully
openly and authentically as
and at the center of these stories are
character so we want characters to be
honest truthful and authentic characters
not that the character is always telling
the truth I don't mean that but we're
presenting the character as honestly as
we can and through the years going way
back now I'm going back to Stanislavski
which is the early 1900s he caused a
great shift in this process of acting
which you probably know about from quote
presentational acting there was a book I
had once in which I wish I could find I
think I've lost it it was actually a
book that was written in the I think
late 1800s that for actors showing all
the positions that are active could hold
to portray or relate an emotion to the
audience and if you look at the early
films the films were certainly the ones
before it sound you can see this you
know what this meant and this looks
another words and this book was a
wonderful book as it showed all these it
says this is how you do it this is how
you act this is how you portray this and
so that's presentational acting and what
Stanislavski was doing in the early
1900's he asked a very simple question
profound question he was struggling with
the fact that in the Moscow Art Theatre
they'd give a performance or he'd give a
performance but the actors he's working
with would give a performance and it
would be powerful and the next night it
wouldn't be it was no consistency
sometimes it would be I feel I think and
other times you'll feel really false and
fake and so he was asking how can we
stay closer to those powerful
performances that feel real or even he
is an actor when I feel like I'm really
connected with the character so he did
this very significant thing he shifted
at that time there's a seismic shift
let's take our mind off of acting and
let's look at the character
and let's talk about the character what
the character wants what the character
needs what's in the way of the character
getting what he wants how he's trying to
get what he wants let's look at what the
character is doing and stop thinking
about what I am doing as an actor or
what the other actors are doing is act
or how we think we should portray this
let's try to understand the character
that was the big shift instead boskie
shifting to the character now this led
to as you know the group theater and
Harold Clurman Bobby Lewis that were
Adler Strasburg Sanford Meisner all the
peoples in the group theater who studied
a lot of them studying with Stanislavski
went and learned from him and this has
changed the way theater was done in this
country the way acting was done this gun
became more realistic and then she
became known as method acting
but it was a focused point let's present
real life real baby rather than
presentational behavior or acting by
activating pretending pretending to be
said to pretending to be angry can we
actually do performances where that
genuine emotion is is exhibited and felt
within the actor and that's what
happened and then Strasbourg and
Strasbourg and Elia Kazan Elia Kazan I
don't know if you know that he's the one
that created the Actors Studio and
eventually turned it over to Strasbourg
who turned it into what he's turning at
that Actors Studio and then Sanford
Meisner who was also a member of the
group theatre felt he felt there's a
better way now he split off from that
group Strasbourg went ahead and formed
and reinforced the method acting the
method acting which is the actor trying
to stimulate those emotions from within
himself based on his own life history
sense memory experiences and seeing can
i generate those genuine feelings
Meisner said and that's not what the
folks primary focus should be Meisner
said the focus needs to be on the other
character that on the event what is
actually happening in the moment
so that so that was a split that
happened in the group theater inter so
now we have the method for technique or
method and then we have the Meisner
technique which are different but they
actually complement each other now I'm
coming through theater at the same time
I actually studied I'm very happy to say
this with some of these people I study
with Harold Clurman Bobby Lewis Stella
Adler a lot of people from the group
theater I did not study with Sanford
Meisner I wish I had but I've studied a
lot of his work and there's a great
documentary out there by Sydney
on the my Sutekh he follows information
for a whole month through a whole class
and so I've studied that so my pursuit
was similar to this there's got to be
another way not dismissing any of this
but seeing these as stepping stones
which I've done in my wife's life
studying all this and I keep
experimenting and it was about 10 8 10
years ago something hit me which was
rather startling to me which was and I
was actually in Amsterdam teaching at
the Binger Institute at the time and
that actors are dealing always always
their pursuit is to try to become the
character the director is helping
everybody's helping trying to get the
actor to become the character and the
actor is dealing with certain obstacles
enormous obstacles in that path but what
hit me at one point was one of the
biggest obstacles to the act of any
actor to be able to do that was the
actor themselves and ironically he
intent to become a character gets in the
way of becoming the character the
intention the hard work of becoming the
character will get in the way how can
you become a character when all you're
thinking about is becoming the character
that is not what the character is
thinking about
now it's really bizarre when I started
to play with this idea when an Amsterdam
I said and I didn't really know this is
why I'm saying I discovered it I didn't
really know what I was saying I said to
the group of directors now these are
working directors and have made many
films and all professional directors and
this whole workshop was on working with
actors and I said to one of the
directors I tell you what did here's
what you need to do you need to stop
directing the actor because what well
this is what the whole workshop is I
said stop it stop directing the actor
direct the character and he looked at me
and tell you the truth Ken at that
moment I wasn't quite sure what I had
said and it's one of those moments in my
teaching career one of those wonderful
moments where I say something and I have
no idea what it means but I have a
feeling it's good but really there's
something there and so that I remember
the director said well show me what you
mean so I said okay I turned to the
actor and I stopped I didn't talk to the
act I talked to her character and I'm
talking to her character and I'm
starting asking the character questions
now this is where the interrogation
started I said asking and what I'm
seeing is suddenly this character's
start to emerge this character starting
to emerge because I'm questioning the
character I'm not saying to the actor
this is what I want you to do I'm not
questioning the character about what she
thinks about the her character I'm not
doing any of that I'm just talking to
the character say who are you what are
you doing what are you doing why you
want this one and starting to probe
inside the end what happened was this
character in which we all said they want
my god this is amazing how the rest of
the workshop went that way when shifted
dramatically still with me not quite
sure what I had done but feeling this
I'm on to something and it was during
that workshop that the word
interrogation came up because someone
said what are you doing I said well I'm
interrogating so that's where the world
that's what it became called the
interrogation process it wasn't until
much later I kept doing this I kept
experimenting as I
my whole life experimenting with
everything that I kept using this
technique teaching this technique even
though I didn't quite understand it and
starting to deconstruct it and sit and
spent a long time which as I mentioned
to you before and Ella and I have been
doing this
still deconstructing is still trying to
figure out why it works and how it works
and way deeper and deeper this to
understand what this process is and what
became clear to me after a while not
immediately was that I'm talking to a
character now I'm asking a character
very simple but very profound and
questions pushing the character to
answer questions after that experience
in an Amsterdam
I kept exploring what I had stumbled
upon and I literally mean I feel like I
stumbled upon something in many forms
and there was one time I was working on
I think it was here in Los Angeles and I
decided to ask myself okay I'm talking
to an actor I'm sorry I'm talking to a
character and I'm questioning the
character I'm interrogating the
character I'm pushing the character and
the character is responding
maybe resisting me but is not refusing
this engagement and I know that this
makes no sense at all it's totally
illogical first of all as we talked
about before the character the character
does not know that she's in a movie does
not is not in a movie so I'm not ask
questions about moviemaking line script
like but I can ask questions about who
they are what they want what they doing
anything I want but the question became
to my mind who is she talking to
Who am I because if she's not a
character in a movie she's not
participating in a movie but she's just
herself she doesn't have a director Who
am I
and then it became clear to me I am NOT
a character that she's responded Who I
am I am the voices in her head but I
called the committee the committee is
the collection of voices that we all
have each of us has all these voices in
our head that we'd have debates with the
discussions that have opinions and
attitudes and that what I'm doing is I'm
giving voice to the committee in the
characters have not the actors that the
characters had in fact I am creating a
character by creating the characters
committee and allowing the character to
respond to her own committee and her
response every response creates the
character so I'm creating the character
from deep deep inside the character
actually without the help of the actor
the actors attitude of feelings or
opinions about the character are fine
but they as many actors have told me
there's no room to that the character is
working so hard to manage her way
through this interrogation there's no
room for the actors imagination or
creativity to come in although I do
believe unconsciously it is working but
the character is being formed from
inside the character to the point where
the character can take over completely
so it's almost like this character has a
mini court trial going on and they're on
the witness stand they've got this trial
attorney that's just grilling them yeah
but it's really their own voices their
own if they're from the past whatever
what their own thoughts that's just just
relentless yeah and and so does it break
them down does it cause them to you know
you've seen films where someone will
have a meltdown on the witness stand is
it almost like that they're having a
mini meltdown inside themselves as a
character oh yeah tell me yet they've
been breakdowns have been some
extraordinary things that have happened
even to the point where it has
frightened other people in the room with
the power of what's happening which I
can tell you about one which is
interesting where one character I draw
the a character to the point of suicide
and she was ready to kill herself
and we're the other people and we'll
kept begging me to stop because they
were so frightened what she was going to
do so finally I did stop and the actress
his name was Catholic and I was talking
to the character I don't remember the
character's name so they want me to stop
sleight and the way to stop is just to
address the actor by her real name
and I said Cathy okay we're going to
stop and she was like oh okay why why I
said well the people home is scared I
said are you okay Cathy she's I'm fine
why do we stop in other words the
separation between character actor is
really profound that the character can
be going through most extraordinary
emotional experiences and the actor is
fine the actor is protected from that
the actor is experiencing it obviously
because it's happening within the actor
but wants to stop it they're done
they're over so it's so it's running
very deep inside the character and
getting back to a moment about
Stanislavski and all of that and going
back to the whole history and the group
theatre and Strasbourg and meisa and all
that the way I see the work that they
were doing that I feel I'm totally in
line with is they were always looking
for how can we get closer to the truth
of the character how can we stop
pretending stop manufacturing I think
this is what the method has done this is
what's Stanislavski was going after this
is what the Meissner team technique is
done this is what a lot of other
teachers whether it's Grotowski or viola
Spolin they're all moving towards
authenticity and what I feel I'm doing
here as I've found yet an extension of
what they're doing I feel like I've
actually going all the way back to
Stanislavski I've shifted back to the
character again some of my problems with
the the method and Stanislaw Strasbourg
even though I am a member of the Actors
Studio both here and in New York invited
I was invited by Harold Clurman which
cool and here I was invited by Mark
Riedel I'm a member there and I see the
work they're doing my problem is there's
a little too much focus on acting and
how the actors made and what I've done I
said let's shift to the character let's
take your mind off of the acting because
if you if you're always thinking about
the acting while you're trying to be the
character there's no room for the
character's mind I want to stimulate the
character's mind the ironic thing about
this technique is as opposed to probably
all other ways of approaching acting I
think this technique the interrogation
technique is director dependence or
other dependent the actor cannot do it
by themselves because you cannot sit
there and think okay I'm going to shut
down my actors mind and open up my
characters mind so as you think that the
actors mind is working it has a job shut
it you can't shut your brain down the
interrogation process because it's so
powerful and overwhelming forces the
actors mind adrift into the background
forces the character's mind and
personality to emerge so it needs
another person not necessarily the
director but it's good if it's the
director these are the person for that
that to happen so I feel like I'm
actually right in line was where
Stanislavski was like let's shift off of
the actor back to the character I've
just taken it a few steps further into a
very powerful and it's very fast it can
happen in a matter of minutes but you've
seen I do humbly believe that what I've
done and what I'm doing because this is
a constant process is I'm continuing the
work that started with Stanislavski and
Strasbourg and Meisner and viola Spolin
and kotovsky a lot of these legendary
explorers of the acting process and
continuingly to shift the focus back to
the character to relinquish from the
actor the responsibility of creating or
pretending to be something and allowed
the actor to experience the character
that actually
lives within them now as I said before
this the challenging part of this
process is it takes two people a
director and an actor or an actor and
somebody else the actor cannot just do
it by themselves it's an engagement now
the beauty of that is it's an engagement
it is part of the acting process where
the actresses I'll be the character you
interrogate means suddenly they're in an
improvisation which they understand it's
interesting this takes pressure off of
the actor the actor doesn't have to have
any answers at all
many times I've worked with an actor and
we've been talking about a character
like oh I don't know that she think this
is so you think that I don't know I say
well let's ask the character they go
great then we go in an interrogation may
only take 30 seconds and bam the answer
is out we got it great so the we allow
the actor to do what they want to do
which is act is to be the character an
example of this is a couple years ago I
directed a play I direct a lot of
theater and hydrect film television and
director play 11 actors now 11 actor we
went through a 10-week rehearsal process
this way using interrogation first the
interrogation was in the casting process
which is a startling thing to watch it
was startling for the actors to get up
there and read for a part and the first
thing I do is I start interrogating the
character there is no preparation
there's no warning and you watch the
actors and within a second the actor
will go right back into the character
happily they don't want to be questioned
they don't want to be told what to do
they want to be the character then I'm I
base my casting process on the
characters that are revealed
inside the actor more than their ability
to read or to perform because I'm
looking for authenticity now I've cast
11 people this way 10-week rehearsal
process and during that process I am
teaching these actors how to interrogate
besides interrogating them as a
characters I'm teaching them how to
interrogate each other because the
danger is another danger the challenges
and theater they're going to do the play
every night
and one thing that's once you see the
interrogation process the ironic thing
is actors are very good at it
because it requires improvisation it
requires as I said before playing the
committee claimed multiple characters
and so what if I was interrogating you I
could shift from an ally to a nemesis to
a mother figure in other words I have to
be able to do that so actors are very
good at it so I'm teaching these actors
how to do this because it's a play and I
have a problem here these actors have to
do this play every night in a film I can
interrogate an actor right before a
performance get them exactly the state
of mind I wanted to be them and send
them in the scene and film it I'm done I
can't do that in a place every night
it's a different performance so I'm
teaching these actors how to interrogate
each other as the play is running and
this was the plan the actually the event
that was going on backstage was far more
fascinating than what was going on on
stage and I rarely saw it because
backstage the actors are interrogating
each other before every entrance I have
an entrance in five minutes can you
interrogate they're doing that backstage
so that the actor can come on on stage
fully in character not have to be
standing there waiting for the cue line
that come out and try to hit an
emotional state that they know that
supposed to be they're already in it
because of the interrogation that's
going on backstage fact it was one in
one of the actors who did a lot of
interrogation backstage we come to me
after performance you know how was
Koreans entrance it was great great I
tried something new
he's talking about what he was doing
backstage to send her on and wanted to
know for me how it worked so there was
this now so we had a process there with
these eleven actors they were working
together like a team helping each other
get into character deep into character
before every entrance the play by their
way was fantastic
you know backstage I heard was really
phenomenal but I never got to see it I'd
get to hear about it so you're saying
that the interrogation process works
when there's an other person
interrogating them yes so let's take
something where
slightly different scenario maybe I'm
kind of making a different way around it
in that let's take a movie like the
revenant
and let's take few glasses character
before the bear attack
so he's alone in the forest how are you
interrogating Hugh glass to be you know
stumbling upon the bear or encountering
him how are you getting him ready for
that okay first I'm just getting back to
what you said the beginning
interrogating involves someone else so
the interrogation process is usually
between someone who's not in the scene
and the person who is in the scene so
whether there's one person the scene of
12 people he makes no different matter
okay that each actor needs that other
person and usually someone who's not in
the scene got it alone but getting two
and how do you interrogate someone to
play a scene like your glasses scene
where he's going through the forest the
woods and then he's attacked by a bear
one thing you got to be very clear about
now the interrogation is pretty simple
yet profound for a moment like that but
first of all you can remember in any
scene the character that you're
interrogating does not know what's
coming up in the scene this is a problem
between the character and actor the
actor knows Leonardo DiCaprio he knows
exactly what's going to happen there's
going to be a bear he could have to
fight it off got it
the character doesn't know that no this
is the power of interrogation I've got
to get his mind back into the characters
mind and away from the actors mind the
what the actor knows this is a little
detour what the actor knows what's
coming up in the scene the lines I have
to say what I have to do that's all
there but it's in the background okay
it's not driving everything because it
can't drive everything because it is not
known by the character I will trust that
it'll always be there I will trust it
the actors will always say the lines
they'll follow the stage and they'll do
the mechanics no problem so it's not
about the mechanics I'm worried about
what I'm worried about is the mindset of
the characters or interrogating your
glass before the bear I have to know and
so does few glass have
No what the hell are you doing what are
you doing where are you going and and
what are you expecting now in the
interrogation I could say okay I could
be talking to them where you're going
okay you got to go you're going to get
that you're gonna let's let's say he's
looking for food I'm just making this up
because I don't recall when he was -
he's just moving but he knows what Hugh
glass knows what he's doing even if we
look at the scene we're not sure what he
knows what he's doing
and I'm through the interrogation I am
going to plant in his mind or eject or
question and we're going to establish
through me between me and Hugh glass
what he's doing what he's looking for
right now through that interrogation I
could also I can start to insinuate
potential danger you know you're all
alone you're all alone out here yet
and what if something happens now he
knows as the actor I'm setting the
character up for what the environment of
what's going on actually setting the
character up for the scene
the actor knows that because I bear
coming Hugh glass is just saying yeah I
know it's David but I'm fine you got
your life I'm a guy I got my rifle I'm
fine I said you sure could you handle
something something or whatever Elco
blood no I'm now I'm I want to get him
into a mindset a specific mindset of my
choice the mindset could be I'm fine I'm
in no danger at all that's one mindset
another mindset is I know I'm out here
alone and I shouldn't be and this is a
stupidest thing you should ever do
that's a different mindset where do I
want to take him what mindset do I want
to put him in and I can set up that
mindset and then the beauty of
interrogation is you work with the
character you're interrogating the
character and you set up a mindset a
belief system and attitude just before
the scene a lot of actors will talk
about that moment before the scene where
what are they thinking about just before
the scene when interrogation I can
create that anything I want and then
what I do which I love because I send
them into the scene naive
an actor will go into the scene with a
plan this is disastrous because the
actor when's the last time you went into
a 3-minute moment your life with a plan
knowing what you're going to say and
what you're going to do and how you are
going to reacts we don't do that that's
not authentic it's acting my job is to
send the character into a scene naive
having no idea what's going to come on
because I want the genuine authentic
reactions to the events that happen to
the other lines Liz said to the attack
of the bear to the realization that he's
been stupid whatever I wanted to happen
authentically I don't want him to plan
it the actor will try to plan it the
character can't plan it so if I get him
in the mind of the character believing
something totally different than what's
going to happen then he will react to
every single moment authentically and it
will probably surprise him
it probably surprised me the guarantees
I can make to every directors if you
work this way and you send a character
into a scene naive without a plan
knowing that yes the actor will say the
right lines into the blocking and do all
that but without a plan for the
emotional journey he's going to go
through how he's going to react it ain't
no plan and guarantee number one the
actor will not know what he's going to
do at all certainly the character
doesn't know care the character is just
going to it actor 1 you the director
will not know what he's going to do but
everything he does will be authentic and
that's what we're going for and then you
get to choose in post-production as we
talked about before which moment you
want and then when you do take two you
set them up slightly differently a
different mindset if you're more
cautious mindset this time Peter glass
maybe a mindset of deriving himself
stuck what are you doing out okay then
him trying to convince himself he's
going to be okay and he shouldn't be out
there he will react differently then now
if you do it three or four takes like
that and he reacts differently and
you've shot them all
realize the range of material you've got
that you and it's all authentic you can
build the most beautiful thing possible
do you think that a director can be an
effective director if they themselves
have never taken acting classes or just
maybe one or two little one-day
workshops do you think they really need
to dive into taking a full semester or
several you know a year of acting
classes to really know what it's like to
be the person that they're directing
again you've done 12 questions in my
mind I heard one there's a lot first of
all the first thing you sell goes back
different can they be an effective
director without it yeah it's really
where you started with right absolutely
they can be oh they can okay it doesn't
mean you have to have a studied acting
or been an actor do you don't have to
know okay you know there are a lot of
directors who are very good and very
effective about it now that's because of
who they are and I don't know what all
that training background and history is
but looking at the other side if you
want to be the best director you could
ever be then take an acting class and
writing we talked about writing but take
an acting class and take an acting class
with other actors not an acting class
where it's just two or three directors
trying to learn how to act because that
bill that you'll all hold each other
down but if you get an acting class with
an actor some really good actors and so
you can experience what it's like to go
through the process you're going to
experience what it's like to get a
script and set to break down a scene you
could this be what you like to do the
homework you could experience what it's
like to get up there with another actor
who you don't know what they're going to
do and you're trying to engage with them
and you're trying to engage with the
power of the scene you're trying to
engage with your character and you can
do this week after week after week after
week now you're getting to experience
what it's like to be an actor and the
important thing here is not how good an
actor you
you could be the world's worst actor
doesn't matter it's the experience it's
getting inside the shoes of the actor
going through that so you understand
this is what they have to go through
this is the challenges they face your
whole perception of talking to them and
what you're asking them to do will
change because you'll know you can't
just ask them to be angrier that doesn't
work you can't ask them to be more
sympathetic or show you a little more
vulnerability because it doesn't work
you'll understand from your own
experience not just because I said it or
not just because some teachers said it
to you don't do that you'll understand
what works you'll understand what works
for you and chances are the things that
work for you you will start to use those
things when you start talking to actors
because you know it work for you maybe
it'll work with them very valuable some
of our best directors are actors some of
our best directors come from theatre one
thing I want to say about theater
directing since one this theater
directing is very different from film
directing because in terms of
relationships with the actors because in
film directing I can direct a scene I
can spend a whole day on the scene and
do the range of performance as we talked
about before and get that range and get
enough and then I will build a scene
that works and theater I have I don't
have that option I have the option of
rehearsing with them and trying to lobby
different things but eventually I have
to get those two actors to a point where
they can do it all by themselves every
night it's a it's much more challenging
way more challenging then film the
difference it's a different challenge
way more challenge it in terms of
working with actors to get them to be
able to repeat something every night or
come close to something or stay
authentic every single night so I highly
recommend besides directors taking
acting classes direct theater I can say
try it you'll be amazed at how
it is because you have so little control
over those actress so little so what if
an actress thinks I haven't taken any
acting classes but you know I don't need
to I I know human beings I can I know
more about someone than they know about
themselves doesn't matter but you watch
them and you're observing the opposite
this is a director director sir
what are you observing in a director
that says they don't need acting classes
but you're seeing what seems like here
you say that any questions no no no no
no it's pretty much well sometimes I
hear you say it I don't need this on you
do you know do you know what I hear
resistant arrogance oh okay
and I also hear fear Oh a lot of
directors I mean our arrogance yes okay
think I know how to do this I'm not
saying they're wrong but the arrogance
is doesn't help you it doesn't help you
because it puts up a barrier between you
and the actors so a lot of them feel
that they know that also the fear a lot
of actors I mean I'm sorry
a lot of directors are afraid of actors
they won't admit it and in a statement
like you just said I hear it okay I know
how to do what I do in other words I
don't need to engage with this other
human being on a collaborative
vulnerable level I know I know how to
talk to them it's just a bit like I took
psychology I took this I've you know I
used to be at this I used to be at that
you know I was a life coach I was aware
of whatever I know how to do that and
I'm saying you're telling me that you do
not want to engage with them on a
one-to-one basis in terms of the
exploration of something that has
absolutely nothing to do with either of
you the thing that has not that is that
has nothing to do with either of you is
a character you're both working together
to create a character and you think that
you know so there's there's a fear
there's a resistance a lot of directors
are resistant they don't a lot of
directors don't want to rehearse on I
don't need to rehearse like
cause cats the best people I can and
then I'm fine don't want to Rin what
don't want to rehearse why would they
not want to could be two reasons one is
they have no idea what to do in
rehearsal now that's a big part of my
job as I teach people what to actually
how to rehearse and this is my whole
career started many many years ago at
the Directors Guild me teaching a list
directors how to rehearse just the
simplest thing in the world now it's not
the simplest thing in the world but
that's what I was teaching and my
teaching career started way back then so
a lot of directors don't know how what
to do
you know you give them a rehearsal so
let's read it and then they talk about
it and they talk about the characters
and then then what nothing so that's one
problem is a lot of directors have not
been trained how to rehearse again
speaking my career for a moment this is
why I have a career traveling all over
the world to film schools world-class
film schools teaching directors how to
rehearse because they don't have in the
film school someone who knows how to
teach directors how to rehearse so
that's one that part the other part is
fear other directors fear being seen as
inept unable incapable and this is a big
problem it's a big problem it's a big
problem with in the whole film world
directors are supposed to know
everything you're the director you
should know is it interesting I'm a
director's coach and all that Nidoran I
teach directors I consult with directors
and many times like coach directors and
I'm known as the directors director at
all them actors in the film there's an
actress coach there that's fine an
actor's coach fine imagine a film is a
was he or he's the directors coach what
he's me why does he need a coat the
whole perception it's not the directors
problem is the problem with the
perception the directors supposed to
have all the answers so directors take
that in embrace that concept I'm
supposed to have all the answers
so I have to say I do have all the aunts
so I have to say I know what I'm doing I
don't need help many many years ago I
on-like teacher the directors guild a
friend of mine who works there gave me a
list of directors that was which is for
another seminar of all the first-time
directors people who came to a
first-time directors seminar said mark I
think you might like to have this list
because you're teaching directors I said
great I promoted a workshop to that list
as a big list and then I had people in
my office just doing follow-up it's
called and one call to one of these
directors I don't know who it was
doesn't matter and they called and the
director said don't call me why are you
calling me while we're doing this what
don't you understand he said I am a
member of the Directors Guild I don't
need a directing workshop now that is
dangerous see that that is in
identifying themselves as a as a
director as a member the directors guild
like I've reached a certain level and
now I will cut myself off from anything
or anything that maybe could help me
know there's a lot of directors who
believe that a lot of directors who live
there and that's what leads to the
arrogance I know what I'm doing now I'm
fortunate very fortunate as a directing
consultant and coach to a lot of
directors all over the world because the
directors I get to meet number one who
take the workshops and especially the
directors I get to work with who asked
me to consult in these films because
these are the directors that are open
and available and humble enough to know
that they can learn more and they can
expand their awareness and expand their
skills and the arrogance is not their
arrogance is not there and then they're
willing to learn and these are the
directors who they're all doing very
very well now let's suppose you're
encountering arrogance from someone and
really what you said before was it was
fear but also to their ego their pride
could be hurt because they're thinking
why do you think I don't know what I'm
doing which is not really what you're
saying you're just wanting to explore
more possibilities and let them know
that you have a class and coaching
available but how can you turn it around
and have it so that they don't feel hurt
that it's about their bill
okay that's a great question first of
all we go back to that resistance and
obstacle thing we talked about before
because if I attack them or approach the
whole thing about their arrogance and
their putting up a wall against other
possibilities
it'll the wall will get stronger so I
can't do that
but if they say I know how to work with
actors I know how do I know all that
usually what I'll say great great let's
let's see how this goes and then usually
what happens and I've seen this in else
has seen this many times start working
with the director and they start working
with the interrogation process two
things happen very quickly first of all
they realize that the interrogation
process is difficult and that's a little
intimidating but they hang in but then
the other thing that they see is what
starts to come out of the characters and
they start to see that they are now
experiencing something way beyond what
they imagined and you probably includes
what they thought they wanted includes
aspects of the character but they start
to see more this is such a rich terrain
in front of them that suddenly the
arrogance drops away so I rely on the
power of what I'm teaching the
techniques of what I'm teaching if I can
take them through these skills and allow
them to experience it it will change the
Atlee is there's another similar
situation when as we get into staging
which we talked about before and when
I'm doing a workshop on staging and
directors all right I know how to stage
this thing I said great and they'll
stage it and I'll look at it and I will
think no this much more you can explore
but rather than tell no you haven't
explored enough you don't get it
I very gently say okay that's that's
great and I'll say to the actor how do
you feel standing there there in the
scene oh god I feel fine I feel fine
Oh fine and I'll say to the director
okay she's standing at the beginning of
the scene and how do you want her to
feel like she should feel really
insecure okay
and I move the actor a little bit to
another place I said no how do you feel
this is awful I feel terrible
I turned to the director I said is that
what you want he says yeah I said well
you got it then he sees Wow you did that
just by moving her rather than argue
about what he knows and what won't work
and wonder my job is to demonstrate to
the directors here's how this works
you can argue whether you need it or not
you can tell me but let me show you how
it works
90% of the time directors are blown away
we had a situation here yesterday with a
writer this is it slightly differently
but not on a script and I interrogated
the writer as the main character in the
script and it took I know he'll share
what it was about
three five minutes five minutes five
minutes five minutes later he first of
all five minutes late he was in tears as
the character who's shaking and then
tears because he was because of what the
character was experiencing and then the
writer what he was experiencing through
the character anyone but God he realized
he had a whole different movie he had a
whole different scenario now he he said
now he starts to understand the power of
what I'm trying to teach it I could try
to explain that to him I go I I don't
need that so writers directors and
actors have to experience these
techniques I can write about it forever
you can see this interview you can watch
this and go I think I got it I think I
know what he's talking about
you could even watch the DVD that you
watched go okay once you're in there
once you're in the room experiencing
that is for writers and directors and
act of these techniques then you will
know it has to be experienced Marc fine
I'm hearing that that is a word that
doesn't have a good connotation to it
what is fine mean to you f ing where did
I use five couple times and maybe I'm
projecting my own worldview onto it but
it possibly it's probably what I'm
hearing that's fine is not a good word
to describe
something in fact it means the opposite
but someone's afraid to let someone know
that I'm not comfortable with it how are
you today huh oh what I say when someone
says I'm fine or how was it that one
scene when you yeah fine it's fine
I will script oh yeah we did some note
do you know let me ask you this is not
an interview of you but let me ask your
huh yes it is an interview when you hear
someone can't say and you say to someone
how you doing I'm fine fine
what are you here I hear that things are
not good but they don't want to say it
so they have to have a good a cover
that's just sort of medium yeah instead
of oh I'm doing great today yes or I had
a horrible time getting here so but I'm
fine they want to close it down yep they
don't want to talk to their clothes and
they're probably saying what you're
probably hearing is yeah I'm fine I'm
doing okay and I don't want to talk
right which makes you think and we think
there's a lot going on there that it's
uncomfortable doesn't she doesn't she or
he doesn't want to go there so when you
say to an actor or someone you work with
how you doing fine you go okay there's
something going on now if you keep
pressing up against that wall you're
going to get a lot of resistance now
your job is to let me see can I get to
it
can I get find another way this is what
my pretty much my whole career find
another way to access the truth with
that individual or with that character
with that writer director actor or
character how can I get around the
barriers that are automatically there
because we're human beings and we put
them up we protect ourselves can I find
another way appropriately to get around
that and get to the truth not only so I
can see the truth but so that the the
person who said fine let's say it's an
actor said I'm fine
my feeling is is also a part of that
person who wants to reveal that you know
that's and that's their committee us and
then there's another voice if I want to
talk about the other voices don't talk
about it in others there's a little war
going on and they
that we all experience so if I can get
to the truth
and get somehow find a way not only so I
can know more but also said he or she
can have the opportunity to reveal it or
even learn something about themselves
quite possibly ok so fine to you doesn't
mean conversations over and it's good it
means hmm think something's wrong but I
think they would be willing to talk
about it if I go around a different way
yeah and I don't keep pushing up against
doesn't sound like things are fine yeah
yep I do it does sound like things are
fine then the walls going to get thicker
mm-hmm yeah and it might even be someone
says something I say something how you
doing that fine and I go okay we're
going to get back to that later
I may just go off on a whole nother
track but with the intention of getting
to what's bothering them if it's an
actor since we're talking a lot about
working with actors and it's an actor
then my concern will be that whatever's
really going on with them is going to
get in the way of their work that day
this an actor I'm working with that how
you do it fine okay we got this this
could get in the way of the work we're
doing today and let's say I'm picking up
on resentment or anger or fear and these
are very general and let's say it's a
Canadian who's actually I've worked with
a lot and I get this fine I go okay
there's a lot of that going on now as
we're working on the scene I haven't
addressed it at all as we're working on
a scene and I start interrogating his
character do you know where I'll go
anger resentment fear as the character I
will allow Ian to express whatever's
going on through the character and this
is when it actually becomes in a way a
little therapeutic and which is another
whole topic because there are therapists
we've been looking at what I'm doing and
wonder we have to if it's another form
of therapy which I will address right
now it's not it's not form of there
because I've had a lot of people ask me
about this along with the hypnosis
question but the interrogation is not a
form of therapy a therapy generally is
intended to help the patient the person
the individual so smooth out the edges
get through life in a much more
comfortable way and deal with whatever
problems he's dealing with interrogation
is absolutely the opposite interrogation
creates chaos I create chaos inside the
characters so that the actor as the
character has to struggle I want them to
struggle I don't want to smooth it out
and want the actor to experience the
struggle that's going on inside the
characters sort see it's the opposite
therapy coming back to your question
about the fine someone's saying fine I
think we all hear that there's a hidden
feelings emotions or truth behind that
and our job as directors is to honor
that we expect it but not forget it and
if we can allow the actors especially a
way to release that through the
characters even if even if it's
inappropriate for the character at the
time that may be a gift to the actor top
three movies every actor should watch
and which performance they should study
that's like in terms of acting doesn't
means story but whether it's Glengarry
Glen Ross whether it's Network I mean
just in terms of acting and performances
okay I'm a top movies and top
performances are two different
categories okay top performances let me
let me have a performance blue Jasmine
okay yeah it was a create play Blanchett
because that was that was to me it was a
stunning performance because in terms of
the way I work I think there are certain
actors when I say actors can't do this
alone there were some actors who have
these amazing abilities to allow
themselves to sink deep into a character
Cate Blanchett is one of them and new
Jasmine's one of those performances
almost regardless of what you think of
the movie just watch her work
the and multifaceted ways because of
different time frames that she had to
experience that character another actor
Daniel day-lewis is similar if you look
at his work in Lincoln gangs in New York
except he's another actor who has found
a way of dropping himself deeply into a
character and one very quickly one
interview I read about him not with him
an actress who worked with him and asked
him at the end of the movie because she
couldn't talk to him during the movie
because he was in character all the time
asked him why he spent so much time with
so much energy just to get into a
character like that and his answer was
he says I'm not a good enough actor to
do it any other way which I thought was
profound he sees himself as a very
limited actor and but he knows what he
needs to do to get deep into that
character if you watch Manchester by the
sea Casey Affleck performance I think is
stunning now regardless of his history
his background and the problems that he
has watch that performance because
there's another actor who has dropped so
deeply into the nuances of the
characters it's sort of sort of
startling Meryl Streep will do this
frequently quickly she's only been
nominated 20 times but I mean there are
certain so there are certain actors who
you watch them and they can literally
disappear you feel that the character
takes on and that's that's that's what
we're looking for
chameleons chameleons in a way but I see
it as a more than chameleon chameleon is
more like I will change myself into
something so which it is chameleon like
but it is I will release mice I will
give myself over Desai this is my
experience my experience of these
actresses and they give themselves over
and just allow themselves to be in that
world but in a way ignoring themselves
regardless of what happens to them as an
individual as an actor they have to be
that it's a total relinquishment to the
character
and it's similar to watch let's say
those performances from those four or
five actors that you mentioned without
turning down the sound and just seeing
the body language yeah the reactions the
expressions of micro expressions yeah
exactly
yeah watch them in detail just watch
them here tonight and watch the movies
which which else should I do we'd have a
whole discussion about that watch it
several times and watch and even stop
and look at and go back and just look at
that moment look at just look at that
reaction and understand that with the
best performance of that reaction was
not planned that stunning reaction
probably was not planned at all it just
happened I remember I was working with
an editor who I've worked with on a
couple films of mine he was showing me a
film that I didn't direct seen and there
was a stunning moment that scene he says
you know that's the only time she ever
did that and that to me was a key thing
that's you know to capture those moments
that happen but first of all the actor
has to allow themselves to give that
unplanned planned performances are death
unplanned performances over swear the
gold is just go in there and just see
what happens so I'm confused about this
I'm sorry I just have to ask so one
thing a director does not want in their
movie is acting it doesn't yes I have
said this and maybe it upsets some
people along with one of the most
dangerous things on the set is an actor
with a plan but I also say what we don't
want in our movie is acting but by
acting acting I mean pretending a
manufactured performance no it's true
there are actors who have won Academy
Awards for what I call acting because
you can it's also well crafted and
presented and considered and worked out
I think what we really want to see what
I want to see I'm not going to be
startled by a brilliant quote
performance
I'm going to be startled by an
extraordinary human being who reveals
themselves authentically on the screen
when I see something that I wasn't
expecting which I feel but generally is
coming genuinely from that character
that was not planned that was not
considered that was not honed sharply if
it just came out that's what I wanted
and that's why I see him like in blue
jasmine or a Manchester by the sea
I see moments like that but I just find
chilling that's what I want
now I've seen a lot of performance that
are very manufactured now there are some
films and some film makers where that
kind of acting is what's required
you watch Wes Anderson's work and stuff
like that that's what's required that's
his style nothing wrong with it that's
the style of that work you could even go
back to Kabuki theater that's a style
what I'm saying because what I want when
I see a movie as I want to feel I'm in
the presence of these he'll genuine
human beings and experiencing them
deeply and profoundly and then it's not
pretense it's not calculated it's
genuine so no acting please which means
you have to stop directing directors
have to stop directing so actors will
stop acting which mean that's why it's
directors switch to interrogation and
form a relationship with the character
rather than the director telling the
actor here's what I want you to do the
director stimulating the character to go
and then find what they do do okay so
instead of Casey Affleck character and
Manchester by the sea if I'm his
director saying you know what Casey I
want you to look really depressed and I
want you to be in this room with no
furniture and instead I'm going up to
him and I'm saying your life is falling
apart and you're here alone in this
dingy room yeah so I've been saying to
his character I've forgotten the
character's name but saying the kts as
his character you're alone of this did
you what what the hell are you going to
do what the hell you're going to do do
you realize that everybody back in
Manchester by this
hates you do you realize that and you're
going to go back there so how are you
thinking now I'm getting him into the
into the chaos of the character and I
said okay let's do the scene now we're
doing the scene now he's totally in the
chaos of the character and kind of fight
through that chaos while he's trying to
fight his way through a scene
simultaneously sort of like we all do in
life every day we fight through our own
chaos while we're trying to get through
the daily chaos he's not thinking about
acting he's thinking about survival
seriously how do I get through this how
do I get through this moment I like
quiet the voices in my head that came
through the interrogation the voices are
going mad in his head and he's trying to
quiet those down there sort through
those while he's trying to deal with
whoever this lady who'd meet some
plumbing done of whatever it is and he
said that's what he's dealing with he's
dealing with only what the character is
dealing with not with what Casey Affleck
is dealing with Casey Affleck at that
moment does not matter and quite
honestly I can tell you as a director at
that moment if I was directing him I
don't care what Kasey act like this
thinking I don't care what he's thinking
about the character I don't want him
thinking about the character I only care
about the character I'm going to film
the character not to film an acting
performance the fine line but it's a
significant line